i'm giving you a chance
no one ever gave me a chance
now
ever
since i was a child i've always loved
little puzzles
for me they're a retreat
from the horrors of our world
maybe
they can bring some comfort to you too
mr colson you admit it
three riddles in two minutes
you give me the answers and i'll give
you the code for the lock do you
understand
okay so i just um you want me to
riddle number one
it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied it's your violence
you may find wait wait
[Music]
in this city along with the late mayor
and police commissioner were you not mr
carlson of course
riddle number two
if you
are justice please do not lie what is
the price for your blind eye
oh god brian's he's asking how much it
costs you to turn your back
58 seconds how much nothing how much 10
grand 10 g's a month i get a monthly
payment just not to prosecute certain
cases
you didn't ask me that come on it's ten
days
okay
okay okay don't lose your head mr
carlson just one more to go before your
time runs out last riddle
since your justice is so select
please
tell us which vermin you're paid to
protect
that
the informants you all protect from the
salvatore moroni case how do you know
about that what's his name 20 seconds no
he's gonna kill you i'm a dead man
either way you're talking to a dead man
okay by going this way it's just me but
if i give over that name i have family
people i love
they'll kill them too
one people so much bigger than you could
ever imagine it's the whole system
[Music]
you